hi everyone my name is Jeremy this is
John we're here from the UK we work at a
software company called jugs we love
open source and we love simple tools and
we lock the closure so so today to talk
about temporal doses temporal databases
to Streamy architectures yes a quick
question is anybody heard of at all that
we've built called crux mr. hands up
cool that's a good spread okay so
anybody actually used Crocs cloned or
downloaded it Wow okay I was kind of
expecting like one or two there's a few
we have a point of housekeeping we have
some t-shirts here for trucks if anybody
wants one at the end just come and pick
one up it's this lovely sort of
beautiful t-shirt here and I'd love just
to do this it's a lifetime ambition just
to throw a t-shirt into the crowd so is
there a catch congratulations
so so I talk today after that title is
quite concise I have to put up slightly
more around in bigger terms sorry you
might say how do we handle time in a
Streamy architecture yeah and this this
talk is really is you know it's not as
pronouncing how the sit should be done
this is more the experiences that we've
got if you know we like event streams
with our these architectures and then we
typically run into this problem of how
to handle time so this talk will give
give are those experiences those lessons
that we've learnt and also leading up to
you why we built trucks and crooks so
yeah crux it's it's a big thing for us
and come on so exactly how it works and
why it's great but first we need to
start back at the beginning so streaming
architectures event streams why are they
great I mean we love them we we think
they embody a lot of principles that we
like about closure about immutability
about consistency and and they really
offer us a way of thinking about how we
should be able building systems in the
future yeah if I say like we love events
dreams just the simplicity the decoupled
nature of the architecture that you end
up with and the way that you can extend
these architectures these how an event
stream and then you have these
lightweight components around it that do
one thing and one thing particular I'll
be like the UNIX philosophy and of
course this whole modern concept of
event streaming really started with the
release of Kafka and popularized around
the community that evolved around that
including the likes of Martin clapman
who got up on stage and said actually
when you have this catheter-based
streaming architecture it actually sort
of resembles this unbundled view of a
database across your enterprise you know
once you put all your canonical
information into Kafka everything else
is just just a view on that so your
existing database is all your existing
applications they're just they're just
materialized views what matters is that
you or your Kafka streams are durable
and and then you can replay everything
and fix all your mistakes and go back in
time and do whatever you need to to to
get that flexibility in your
architecture and this really means that
your streams are like the central
nervous system for your your
applications so that's a
quick history lesson yeah just to make
this sort of obvious to restate this
obvious point like we love the events
teams and we love the look but the log
is not enough like you have this stream
of facts these facts come off the log
and they're great they're interesting
but what we often want to do is callate
those facts and look at them over a span
of time so you might have a trader for
instance that yes a trade goes through
that's an interesting fact that one
trade but how are these trades coming
together to represent how I did during
the day like have I made a profit or
loss how my trades done throughout the
last year it's really time when it comes
in that brings that meaning so the facts
are on these are these logs and to make
them more specific we really just think
that the log is storage the log is an
append-only sequence of records it's
it's it's it's an implementation of this
sort of high-level concept of an event
stream where you know it's just a
sequential order of events that are
unbounded but a log is just a pending
sequence and when we think about logs we
think about ingestion time primarily the
events that go onto our log we're
definitely recording the ingestion time
we know the order that they're ingested
but that's not the same thing as the
event time and often we need to extract
the event time information from outside
from within the records so the question
then is how do we how do we make Kafka
this this this lovely sort of database
foundation as things that's I said it
ticks all the boxes for acid in in
Martin's view of the world but it
doesn't provide curry ability so how can
we add a generic layer to interpret the
actual order of events on top of the
event streams and then from an
information model perspective just just
adding the information isn't enough we
need to be able to change what we know
invalidate information or perhaps even
delete it all together depending on you
know if we have legal requirements that
sort of thing which leads us to by
temporality serve item per allottee is
it's a problem that you don't always
know that you have and I speak from this
personally it's like you build use
eventually even systems and then the
events come in and you want to make
sense of them and then you you quickly
run into this problem so we actually
spoke to someone the other day and they
were like I don't understand what the
fuss is it's just
that's kind of true but the Devils in
the detail
so by temporality is it's just defining
time on two different axes so let's go
through what they are press that so
first we have transaction time and
transaction time is just saying this is
when a fact is transacted so I think
people know this if we have an event log
it's when that event was transacted onto
the log
it's good news and and then this gives
us like a audit log so we have all our
events there we've got them forever
we're safe in the knowledge that they're
audited you know they're there put it
into the other thing it gives us is
consistent queries so we have
transaction time this is this is the
kids are saying well all your
materialized views could be at different
points in the history but as long as you
know the point that that materialized
view is at then then you know that
actually you're always gonna get the
same result out of it yeah there's a bit
of a thing because if you query as off a
point in transaction time transaction
time the path doesn't change so those
queries will always give the same
consistent results then we have valid
time and this is not when a fact is
transacted but this is when a fact is
said to be true so if I go back to that
trading example imagine you have like a
big enterprise as a you know it's
offices across the world and a trader
enters in a trade and that's when they
think this this trade is true this this
fact this traders made is true at this
time but then this this trades it'll
weaves its way through the enterprise to
different time zones and finally gets
our event stream and this is when it's
transacted and I've been in a situation
where you you know you might argue with
the trailer because the traders like hey
I'm doing this query as of this point in
time but I can't see my trade I know
it's there and you're like wow you know
our system didn't see it it wasn't
transacted but they're like yeah but
it's that's when it happened that's when
it actually happened why can't I see it
so it's just valid time it's when a fact
is true that the business really cares
about the other great thing about valid
time is that valid time is more
forgiving it's more fungible you can
insert into valid time past so if you
imagine that
trading example imagine you have a
trader that has a system they enter
their trading t but then there's another
trade that they writes on a piece of
paper and it goes through a slightly
different system and it might turn up
like an hour later but they want it to
apply to the past they want to insert it
into that valid time past and if we've
only got transaction time there's always
increasing we have to expect transaction
time we can't do that so valid time
gives us that sort of more meaningful
business care about and that we can work
with the password yeah it's when you
bring these two things together that you
get the beautiful combination of by
temporality yeah so you can query as
well valid time but then you can also
create a sort of transaction time put
this two together to get the consistent
view of the time line the people really
care about yeah and so this this by
temporal modeling is not like a new
concept as such people have been doing
this for decades especially in heavily
regulated industries and financial
services or insurance the the
regulations require that you store an
audit log of everything that's going on
so they had to keep transaction time
long before that was fashionable and
equally they needed this is this valid
time view of you know when was my
insurance policy valid so these these
concepts on new really
they've been implemented in many
databases in many ad hoc ways across the
world and sure a lot of those systems
are still ticking on fine
but a lot of it a lot of it is
handcrafted and and so for decades
people have been adding new columns to
their relational schemas that you know
this is when it was valid from this is
when it was valid to this is when it was
updated and they never delete the rows
in their tables and these are really
hand rolled solutions and it forced you
to make up front decisions about which
table is gonna have these properties and
then how do I rewrite my sequel
statement hadrat and add indexes to
accommodate this fact so this
handcrafted nature of by temporalities
what drove people to add temporal
support to the sequel standard so 2011
we had a whole bunch of new operators
you could do this as of time currying in
sequel but the reality is no one's
really using that in earnest like
they're definitely all users and the
database vendors are picked up you know
this this standard but they're
implementing it to different degrees and
it's still quite a complex thing to to
have to decide right I'm going to make
this bitemporal like it's something you
have to cognitively think about in order
to to apply it right
and it just being a default and as a
result because the tools for doing this
aren't very simple we argue that by
temporality is an open problem so going
back to the main question so we've
defined how you want to perceive time as
how I want to model it and we like event
streams so how do we put these two
together what are the approaches that we
can use to solve this problem well
regardless of the approach we're gonna
have to stream in the data from I got to
consume that data from our streams and
that could be across one stream or
because we could be drawing data across
multiple streams and maybe you want to
do simple things like a stateless
transformation in which case easy but
the moment you want to care about
joining across multiple streams and
doing sort of more stateful things
you're gonna have to have some kind of
aggregate state and maybe you're gonna
store it locally maybe going to put it
up and some big distributed index but
these are sort of fundamental operations
that you need and then we either going
to produce a new event but on another
event stream or we're going to expose an
API for interactive query so with that
in mind what kind of approaches can be
used for actually building our aggregate
state Palmateer allows view so one thing
we can do is to take a monolithic
database a traditional database take
Postgres take take Oracle and take the
take more a DB it has a temporal support
or you could just yeah do do the
handcrafted solution again these are
these are ways to address the problem
and certainly if you have temporal
support and you think your database does
have anything apps that you need to do
it's it's a it's a valid approach now
you get a lot of benefit in terms of
development tooling and operational
tooling to make it happen but there's
some downsides yeah you could use crooks
as one of those but it has downsides
these are downsides so if you use a
database if you bring in like a monolith
you have to consider the cost so
somebody might have to cut a check for
like a large enterprise sorrel license
and then you have to provide the ongoing
support and maintenance and look after
those databases they're quite expensive
and it but it could also be we're sort
of moving away from the philosophy of
events teams of having just simple
things doing one thing particularly well
if we're bringing like a huge DB system
to take care of our time problem and
then it might just do too much there
might be a sledgehammer
at this particular nut or it could be
that you bring in a DB one of these at
the bottom and it doesn't quite do what
you need and we've been in this
situation trying to sort of shoehorn in
things like the bio temporality and
other things that you absolutely have to
have and then it's it's like you might
need to eventually introduce some other
store and then you've got the worst of
all worlds you've got breadth of these
different database systems to help you
so it would be good if we care to sort
of get back to a simple way yeah and one
of the problems is that yeah what in
order to find out if that database is
enough you know it's Postgres enough you
have to go down that path and then
realize I'll wait no it doesn't have
good enough free texture so I'm gonna
have to bring in elastic search anyway
in which case you have this
proliferation of it's an ad-hoc how am I
going to solve the event ordering
problem across these multiple databases
so you end up with like two months three
months so yeah this is this is an
approach but it does come with this sort
of inherent risk another thing you can
do is to use stream processing tools so
things like yeah Kefka streams blink
Samms or whatever that they're very good
tools for running things at high scale
on top of something like Kafka so
they're they're inherently built for
throughput and that legacy comes from
complex event processing where
historically you know machines are very
small and they could literally only fit
so much information about like a recent
history in them so you're really
thinking about throughput and in that
little trade-off between cost in terms
of retention and latency and correctness
you know these these are really oriented
towards throughput systems but the good
thing is that these systems do have
native support for event orderings so
Casca streams you can say I want to
extract my event timestamp out of the
record and use that to manage windowing
so when doing is the way you would
manage sort of valid time using a stream
presidential but windows are sort of
quite a mechanical way of thinking about
the problem because they offer you know
the ability to say well I want to
rearrange the event order for like the
events that come in in the last 10
minutes or the last day or the last week
and you can do it you know sliding
windows tumbling windows etc and the
only way to really model valid time
using this is to take an unlimited
window to actually say I want to
make this window go right back to thing
anytime and therefore I can reorder the
events ad-hoc using my stream processing
tool so this works that you can do this
in Ancaster streams but again there's
some downsides yeah I mean the main
downside of a window is that if if you
want to get lots of meaning from it and
query across time you have to widen out
the window and then it's not really a
window it's like it's an ad-hoc queries
for it's like a window is really
optimized for sitting on that firehose
of data the events going through and
providing you some insights in a
windowed way if you try and shoehorn in
like generic query or you know the
ability to look at history then it's not
really what it's built for and then
that's when you get some performance
problems with them yeah and you have to
make decisions like how big should my
window be and you always have to make
these guesses as you know what you're
doing like the extreme person tools
imply that you have a throughput problem
actually a lot of time it's modeling
problem and also the windows won't give
you the ability to sort of have this by
temple's state so within your aggregate
you're not going to be able to say show
me make a decision about how to change
the state based on like the past five
states so you gonna have to maintain
that sort of temporal state within the
window yourself so there's a lot there's
a lot of there which they don't solve
inherently which is why we have really
only a third approach to looking at this
yeah this is to try and build yourself a
materialized view and do it that
lightweight way the unbundled approach
just one thing doing one thing well that
ingest from the event stream I'm gonna
talk about that now so a case study so
this is something actually happened so
we were in a situation a bit like this
about trading enterprise situation that
I described earlier and here you've got
different trading platforms across the
world they're all taking trades and
eventually those trades will come into
our stream our event log and here you've
you can see on point 70 much detail but
you can see it's a conflict here between
valid time and transaction time when
those trades were made true versus when
they were transacted so this was quite a
constrained environment and there was
quite a lot of three put so hundreds of
millions trades each day and the traders
really wanted
despite temporal capability so they
wanted to do queries to fetch their
truck trades for a particular point in
valid time but of course we need that
transaction time for consistency of
query so we had that we had this use
case they did have a database already
that acted as the event log and act as
the query tool but it was bulging it was
like you know the queries breaking down
they throwing discs at it and it was
becoming a bit of a troublesome child so
so what we did to call a long story
short is we we wanted to go with this
approach of doing something simple we
didn't want to bring in a whole new DB
because I said it was quite a
constrained environment like it's quite
difficult to get things into production
to get people to cut checks and things
so we just did something simple so we
took rocks DB which is a key value store
very simple rocks is like tremendously
scalable it's built by Facebook you know
terabytes and petabytes of data the
ingest fast is really the ingest speed
is really fast so it's a great tool and
all we really did was so if you look at
the the first line in the index a we
just created a key value pair and this
is the key so we had the entity ID which
is the trade ID and then we had the
valid time and we put these two together
in a key and then the value is the trade
and we're ingesting all of this from
this event log that has all of these
trades on okay now if we were to stop
here so forget B and C if we were to
stop this is almost like a bitemporal
system right because you have the log
there which has transaction time so
someone wants a query transaction time
or get at it there's a way to ingest the
log to get it but then the traders that
people actually want this data they can
query it as our point invalid time using
seeks across these keys in the KB store
so I mean that is just it yes extremely
simple and it to an extent it works but
of course if you just have a then you
can't get consistent query because valid
time is this flexible lovely thing that
you can munge and change but then your
queries might be different from day to
day or second a second so that's when
you need the transaction time and this
is just a key so this key
B has these three parts the NTID that
valid timely transaction time and we're
just saying give me this entity as oft
as valid time and just filter out ones
whose transaction time it's after that
John the transaction time that I
supplied to the query what ID might add
off cool okay so now these people can
trade us can get their trades as of a
point invalid time with the consistency
that's great that's useful but we
couldn't do joins or queries so we just
added this extra index which is the
index C and this is like your a ve so
give me all of the trades that have this
field called stock and the values IBM
just gonna be all of those and then this
will then give you the candidate
entities candidate trades that at some
point have had this field this
particular value and then we go back and
we consult the index B to make sure that
these trades
actually had these values at this
particular point in transaction time at
valid time with these by temporal
coordinates and that's kind of that's it
and it's just demonstrating that you can
do something really simple but you don't
have to go for the full by temporal
database solution you can start with
something as simple as a kv store you
know something like rocks and just build
something simple up that ingest from the
transaction log then gives you some by
temporal power and this was quite useful
like we we wrap this in a graph QL layer
so we expose I could graph to our front
end to the business and you know and you
always get some free points because like
you know the UI is a beautiful graph key
well so okay so long way and it was
scaleable like the ingest speed in Ciroc
Sydney was fast we embedded the rocks DB
instances into the application node
instances so of course like your local
query so the creator of fast as well and
yeah I think this seeded some thoughts
like it was a simple way to get that by
temporarily up and running and it was a
nice unbundled flexible architecture so
we went away we thought hmm there's
something in this approach yeah and so
those thought seeds grew and grew and
grew and we ended up with crux which is
an open
source MIT license database that we
support as a product and it gives you
this this capability that we've talked
about and and more there's a few reasons
we really think Crocs is great and
things we really wanted to hit when we
built it one was by temporalities of
course another was eviction which we
haven't really touched on but eviction
is quite a tough problem especially in
you think about streaming architectures
you know if I want to get rid of data
from Kafka but I still want to preserve
replayability
what do I do and I think every
organization is a slight different
approach to this and maybe there isn't
like a completely general solution but
we wanted within our bubble of crux to
solve the eviction problem just you know
just have an approach so we thought
about this and and and solve this
whereas yeah if you go down the stream
processing routes and store your state
in your in your calf extremes thing you
can have to evict from those
materialized custom States doors and all
that sort of thing so we want to keep
them lightweight and simple another
thing we really liked being plagiarist
is data logged so we really want to date
log queries to to give us a sort of full
flexibility and do the sort of graph
algorithms and stuff if we if we choose
to in the future and and the final thing
is a API that actually feels like a
database and so you know when we think
about the unbundle architecture normally
it's like well you have these big system
components and there's API is between
them and they got cathica Connect or
whatever but we we wanted to give
something that programmers can use sort
of that feels much more like a database
you know you know you don't actually
think about the factors and node local
to your application and you're talking
to Kathy others that's all abstracted
away and to make this a reality we
extended John's example which was really
just putting data in with a three other
key operations and these operations are
basically all you need to do something
in this in this model so you want to put
put your documents you want to be able
to delete your documents and delete is
really more like a retraction about that
document invalid time so it's not really
dating because you can always go back to
transaction time and see it but from the
valid time view of the world it removes
it lemon eviction of course which I
mentioned and then compare-and-swap
which is this actual unit of transaction
primitive which which which you need in
order to do complex things where you
have multiple nodes
to coordinate and this will make more
sense in a moment when I explained the
diagram so over on the right you see
we've got a couple of topics and
essentially those those topics a
transaction log it's really using
catheter as a right a headlock and we're
writing each node will write
transactions and those operations which
we just discussed to that to that
transaction log and we don't know if
they've succeeded or not until the node
is red and thanks to the transaction
time we can we can get that consistent
query and block until that node is
caught up and but those operations will
pass or fail depending on whether if it
has a compare and swap operation whether
it allows allows it to happen so you can
do consistency and sort of checks and
make sure you're not changing something
which is change from underneath you and
then so those transactions are stored in
the transaction or and what's actually
in those are hashes of the documents so
we've solved the eviction problem by
only of us throwing the hashes in the
transaction logs the transaction of
never gets compacted it's a single
partition it's linearly ordered our is
the document document log or a document
topic is is more mutable you can remove
them you can just put some new eviction
tombstones and that's how we handle this
so these operations will tell the the
crux node how to how to what to do with
the information is coming in and whether
to add it to the document store or moves
them from the document store and build
up the indexes and we see here it's sort
of internally quite an unbundled and
pluggable approach and in each of these
lines is essentially a closure protocol
so you can swap things out and this is
how we are able to support rocks TV or
LM DB for these different stores you
know they're just just a simple key
value protocol so you know we have high
ingestion requirements rocks DB is a
great candidate but if queries like you
know really want like to get the extra
fifty percent performance boost for
queries then LM DB is actually really
powerful under the hood but because of
this openness and and the ability to
like swap out these components we've
already had you know people out in the
field
users of crux and sort of just working
off the back of cots and github and and
the docs to to to do what they need to
do to make Crocs work for them so these
guys needed to put crux into an
environment on Windows they tried as
hard as they could to get LM DB and
rocks to build and windows they couldn't
do it but then they found exodus which
is like a JVM only
key value store and they wrote crux
Exodus and they published that to github
and and now they can install their apps
yeah locally on their Windows
environments that their clients so this
is a sort of promise of having an
extensible database that people can can
quickly build new pluggable components
in is taking off and something we've
done sort of having reflected on that
original architecture John described you
know that the the ordering of those
indexes required sort of scanning over a
linear history so if you have a document
with lots and lots and lots of the
corrections you're actually gonna have
this sort of yeah linear performance
impact so you have a slow down your
queries so something we did that you
know we went back to academia and we
found these algorithms lit max and big
min and and we realized we could use
these fractal morten curves to incur
these two dimensional coordinates into a
single index so so our points in time
query is actually very fast even for
degenerate case as well as huge amounts
of history and in general crux is just
designed as a way to create database
which which doesn't degrade you know in
regards to how much history it has
shouldn't matter how much histories in
your database the query should always
always be snappy so what we made simpler
john i think that by temporality you
know is these these two timestamps so
how hard can it be but it turns out when
you do it at scale there's lots of
detail there so it crooks aims to make
your life easier if you're facing the
bio-temporal conundrum then we have
eviction the ability to get rid of data
as Jeremy said just crooks trucks is
built from the ground up so you can
evict data like you've got personal gdpr
data that need to exercise evict then
you can do that and it's because the
content and the transaction logs are
split you know so the transaction log
it's completely we can't get that data
there but we can get rid of a bit of it
in the content log and extensibility so
if crooks doesn't do what you exactly
want if there's a part and crooks you
want to swap out and you want to put
your own module in that you can
absolutely do that and we're excited and
already that that's happening to a
degree and Crocs will grow to be
something bigger and better than what it
was a conceived initially so
great so this is a screen shot I'm gonna
go to the real thing pop that there and
say on this string see in a little bit
this is our new console this is a new
console yeah say where user interface so
you know a lot of people look at Crocs
they'd be like ours
that's closures yeah stuff I don't have
to experiment just to try it so this is
a way to try cracks without having to be
brought into closure so it gives you the
power to run queries and run
transactions to see what's going on so
in this view of our database if I'll
just I'll just refresh it this yeah make
sure it very latest so we can see here
it's showing us information about
attribute frequencies so this is just
basically who's telling us what's in our
database we can see we've got 1,700 and
so documents and these are the
cardinalities the different abuse and
the query engine actually uses this
information to optimize the joint order
that it runs and so we can do various
things here what first thing we want to
do is to put data into into a database
so see here we've got transaction we're
preparing this transaction and it
contains basic lots of percent Rees got
some nested documents in there and it's
basically some information about this
trading market we have so if we run this
query and we go to our Eaton output
we'll see we've got this transaction ID
here so this transaction ID is actually
the offset from Kafka and I didn't
mention before actually so we also have
JDBC support so we've modeled the
character semantics in JDBC so if you
want to use Postgres as the backend you
don't have to use character and also you
know see collides or whatever you want
anyway so this offset is is what gives
us the consistent query guarantees so
now if we actually went to like a
different console and we we use that
transaction ID to query against we could
be absolutely sure it's going to be at
the same level and this is in this
instance we don't need to do that
because it's still pointing with the
same crew in it anyway but in principle
that's dusty that's the way it's
manager's scaling so so if we just run
this query that's fine query so this is
what data log looks like I won't try and
explain it I always consider you like to
think it's like a
and it's just filling in the blanks and
we go to the table view we can see
what's in our database so here we have a
huge list of 211 documents and in those
documents we see we got different
attributes here and we can do things
like yeah click around and well first of
all we see what what document don't have
which attributes and we can go in here
and see that this Nasdaq marketplace has
various stock exchanges listed
underneath it and yeah it's it's it's
got various no sorry we're seeing two
stock exchanges one in both in the USA
one New York Stock Exchange one aspect
anyway so we can run these queries we
could also run a query against like a
specific ticket price so maybe we see a
bunch of ticket prices here tech ticket
ooh looks interesting we can click on
that one
and then if we wanted to view the
history for that price we can see the
ballot time history so in we're putting
into the information to the database we
can actually put different ballots on
coordinates within the same transaction
and import lots of data at once and
that's what we're looking at here and we
can also do other more complex things
you know we can add rules and arguments
and we say show me all the ticket data
that's between 10 and 60 now show me all
the tickets that are current between 10
and 60 or maybe we want to do some sort
of more compact to join and see the the
tickers which are greater than 60 here
and are within a particular market so
anyway there's some various capabilities
in the console there and I have to get
you a flavor of what you can do with
crops so let's return back to the slides
and I'll spend a moment talking about um
spend a moment talking about what's
coming up so one of the great things
that martin said in is I think it's 2014
talk was about what to really complete
the streaming architecture vision it's
not just about streaming at the back end
it's about streaming all the way almost
to the to the browser pushing things
through web sockets so streaming queries
is like a really interesting space now
though the crux query engine doesn't do
streaming queries but there's this great
technology called 3d F which is a
a wrapper around some some rust like
project called Tommy dataflow - clouds
days flow and these these allow you to
do streaming data log queries so what
we're working on right now is can we
plug this together into crux and give
you that end-to-end streaming so you're
not just thinking about architecture of
streaming you're also pushing queries
and the new results into the browser for
instance I were also looking into a
we've built cracks connect with sort of
going to that validation process working
in bench markings and we have
transaction functions already in there
so I said there are four operations it's
it's a bit of a lie if you want to do
some sort of than you know events door
sort of projection or modeling paying
crooks you can do that using transaction
functions but that's sort of hidden
behind a flag for the moment but you
know we're very interested in this space
and think about it predicates an
enforcing schema within within the
database but it's also maybe worth
saying that you know trying to think
about how by temporalis and eviction
work together is is quite tricky so
that's one things we're looking at the
lots of other things on our radar and so
everything we've talked about right now
is like point-in-time queries you're
saying I want this by the time this
transaction time but sometimes maybe
you've modeled your date in such a way
that actually you need to see the change
over a range of valid times so it's
almost like a time series use case so
you know crux isn't a time series
database but if you had by temporal
range queries that would give you the
ability to do efficient time series
especially you have columnar compression
we're also very keen to like look beyond
just you know people wanting to use
Crocs picking eating in and and that
using data logs so we're looking at
adding sequel support and JSON for
interaction and then one of the big
constraints of course right now is that
everything has to fit the single node
so you know limits exact exactly how big
your streams can be before you have to
you know shard over time and use a
different node or a different
transaction log so we're very keen on
thinking about adaptive indexing and how
we scale up the the architecture we
currently have so with that we have an
unsession tonight at 7:00 p.m. I will be
there I don't think John can be there
unfortunately but we'll have t-shirts
and we'll do a demo I'll show you more
stuff about the console
get some rattles up and running and
we'll take more of a walk through just
thank you hi
can we get a t-shirt
[Applause]